on fait le point sur l'économie
canadienne et américaine avec Sébastien
mcmans stratège en chef économiste
seniors et gestionnaire de portefeuilles
chez industriel alliances bonjour
monsieur mecman
alors commençons par l'inflation des
États-Unis 8 et demi pour cent en
juillet par rapport à 9,1% en juin
comment est-ce que vous percevez vous ce
léger déclin qu'on observe aujourd'hui
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
maintenant les marchés comme vous l'avez
montré ont pris une grande respiration
aujourd'hui parce que peut-être que les
banques centrales c'est-à-dire fédérales
vendent du Canada vont pouvoir enlever
le doigt du bouton panique donc il y a
encore beaucoup de resserrement
monétaires qui s'en vient donc il y a
encore des gouverneurs la Réserve
fédérale qui parlait dans les derniers
jours que d'ici la fin de cette année le
taux directeur fait passer du 2 et demi
où on est aujourd'hui jusqu'à 4% donc il
y a encore des hausse mais peut-être
qu'on va arrêter le rythme effréné de 75
à 100 points de base par hausse donc il
y a un peu de confort de ce côté-là mais
là je vous dirais qu'on peut penser
qu'on a vu sommet de la butte je serai
d'accord avec ça qu'on a vu semer de la
butte mais de redescendre cette butte là
jusqu'à la cible des banques centrales
qui est de 1 à 3 % et encore beaucoup de
travail à faire oui parce que c'était
pas mal une grosse butte on peut dire au
cours des derniers mois au Canada on
verra les chiffres mardi prochain pour
vous attendez à quoi vous
on s'attend peut-être à la même chose
que du côté américain parce que les
facteurs qui ont poussé l'inflation à
ralentir en juin juillet c'était surtout
le prix de l'essence qui est diminué par
la Cour du mois puis continuer de
diminuer au mot doux donc on a peut-être
aussi des bonnes nouvelles en réserve
pour le chiffre suivant puis aussi des
prix des autos neuves et puis des autos
usagers comment savoir qu'il commence à
avoir de l'amélioration dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de ce côté-là donc
ces facteurs-là devraient se répéter
aussi du côté canadien mais je vous
dirais les banquiers centraux qui vont
regarder beaucoup au cours des prochains
mois c'est des composantes surtout liés
aux salaires et puis la croissance des
prix dans les services qui sont très
sensibles aux hausses des salaires et
puis cette histoire-là risque d'être
peut-être perçu comme étant un peu moins
favorable ou du moins leur signaler que
le combat est pas terminé
en fait on va regarder sur le plus long
terme là pour décider si oui ou non on
doit augmenter beaucoup les taux
d'intérêt donc ce sera sur plusieurs
mois que l'inflation sera scrutée est-ce
que vous voyez cette tendance à la
baisse sur le long terme mais est-ce que
c'est assez pour être optimiste pour les
mois à venir ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
mais c'est raisonnable de penser que
l'inflation va retourner vers la cible
de 1 à 3% si on est optimiste en fin
2023 début 2024 faut quand même être
raisonnable puis penser que l'aire post
covid dans lequel on est il y a encore
des enjeux de chaînes
d'approvisionnement il y a encore des
enjeux de d'approvisionnement dans
plusieurs secteurs mais aussi les
salaires dans le moment qu'on est en
train de voir qui s'accélère encore dans
plusieurs secteurs le coût le coût
unitaire du travail du côté américain
qui est encore à la hausse donc ça ça va
percoler encore d'un secteur des
services donc là ce côté des biens on
voit des améliorations mais du côté des
services quand on passe service on parle
restauration hébergement donc tous ces
secteurs là on est encore en train de
voir une accélération donc c'est un
effet versus l'autre donc
progressivement on va retourner vers une
cible mais il faut pas penser que on va
retourner d'ici la fin de l'année vers
des niveaux d'inflation comme on a vécu
dans les années 2010 l'emploi justement
Statistique Canada publié ces données
pour juillet vendredi 31 mai emplois
perdus au pays le chômage reste quand
même échangé
4,9%, est-ce que le marché de l'emploi
ralentit au Canada
le marché de l'emploi canadien on avait
beaucoup d'avance sur les autres pays
développés puis surtout sur les
États-Unis par exemple on a retrouvé le
niveau d'emploi qu'on avait préco vide
en novembre 2021 chez nous et du côté
américain on vient tout juste de le
retrouver en juillet donc on avait de
l'avance et puis on avait un marché de
l'emploi qui était probablement en
surchauffe du côté canadien le taux donc
le pourcentage des gens qui travaillent
dans la population toute participation
ont été plus élevés qu'ailleurs qui ont
été beaucoup plus élevés que les niveaux
historiques Canadiens donc peut-être
qu'on avait sur embauché parce que vous
savez tout le monde fait face aux
pénuries de main d'oeuvre donc on veut
s'assurer d'avoir la main d'oeuvre
nécessaire et puis là peut-être qu'on
est en train de voir un réajustement du
marché je vous dirais que dans les
derniers mois on a vu beaucoup d'emplois
perdus à temps partiel donc c'est
peut-être ces emplois là qui avaient été
pris de façon peut-être temporaire quand
tu entrain de laisser aller donc faut
penser que tous les stimuli de la covid
par les gouvernements les banques
centrales on est en train de digérer
tout ça et puis il faut s'attendre à
avoir de la volatilité dans les données
économiques au cours des 12 prochains
mois et en termes d'augmentation de
salaire on a vu 5,2 % sur 12 mois en
juillet à quoi vous attendez-vous pour
les prochains mois considérant
l'inflation l'augmentation du coût des
denrées
ça on doit s'attendre à ce que les
salaires continuent demeurer
relativement vous vigoureux en termes de
croissance on entend encore beaucoup
parler que c'est difficile d'avoir la
main d'oeuvre donc on se l'arrache puis
ça va probablement être l'aspect
principal que les banques centrales vont
regarder ce qu'on veut éviter quand on
est un banquier central dans le moment
c'est qu'il y a une spirale
inflationniste qui s'installe si
éventuellement les salaires poussent
trop fort ça va pousser l'inflation de
façon stable dans le temps un niveau
plus élevé que ce qui est désiré donc ça
veut dire plus de travail pour les
banques centrales donc on va espérer que
qui est ralentissement du risque du
rythme de croissance des salaires mais
quand même les tendances qu'on voit dans
le moment montrent que croissance des
salaires puis la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on en a encore probablement
pour un bon merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]